On the next Rick and Morty. Beth, I know it
looks bad but trust me this is life in
the galaxy okay it's totally normal
fine you won't do something I will.
Well, there goes the surprise. I was going to have
us jump on the trampoline after we caught
our first fish. Beth, that's not going to help
I hate to agree with the Rick, but
shouldn't we just let this be. We're
supposed to be on vacation. You're
unemployed Jerry everyday is a vacation
for you okay.
If anything goes wrong which it won't
jump into the same vat of acid I jump into.
I'm very proud of that episode it was a
pretty quick process
come on we kind of wrote the episode as
far as like figuring out the structure
of it in a day and all of us were still
kind of weirded out that it worked it
just came from us love and Batman and we
were talking about what a staple vats of
toxic waste were in the 80s and brandon
johnson who plays goldenfold made the
observation that it's just good for
production value like as if that's why
why so many people died in vats of acid
in the eighties and it was an easy way
to kill people cinematically then we
were just was just off.
It was so dumb all of
us were like this idea is incredibly
stupid the funniest thing we could do is
try to make it a whole episode if
there's something stupid about this idea
with the bones floating up okay well
make the story about whether or not it's
stupid and then go into just like very
dark territory there's no such thing as
a bad idea Morty it's about execution
One of the biggest heroes of it is the
director because the episode was five
minutes short on his own accord he just
did that whole extended plane crash
sequence that wasn't in the script
they said kind of go nuts and I read
that book alive in middle school it may
have traumatized me as a kid.
It's one of the darker
represented you've ever done what did
you do it's more appropriate to ask what
did you do we thought it'd be so
funny if it turned out that all of this
was just an insane run around to get
another I told you so.
But also I think
one of the most merciful episodes we've
ever done like all of us have done
things we're not proud of Jesus Morty
the AARP it's hard out there everyone
deserves to have one acid vat in their
life they can just jump into and have it
do over. Say the vat is good. The vat is good.
And that is the lesson of acid vat.
Catch a new Episode
Sunday at 11:30 only on Adult Swim.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is going to be my Rick
and Morty season 4 episode 9 trailer
video we also have an update on season
five episodes justin roiland did a big
interview about what's going on with the
status of season 5 episodes so we'll
break it down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing a Rick and Morty
merch giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your predictions for the episode on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this this time it's an adventure with
the whole family for those of you on my
last episode eight video wondering where
the rest of the family has been the
second half of the season there hasn't
been a whole lot of the other family
members but I think that's mostly just
because they're trying to take the
episodes back to more of the season 1
season 2 dynamic when it was mostly just
Rick and Morty on adventures and the
family members were just background
characters there were a couple episodes
during season 3 where you had way more
of each family member paired up with
Rick in episodes the interesting
behind-the-scenes reason that they
revealed for that is that when they go
to a lot of different planets in the
families scattered all over the place it
winds up being a ton more work for the
animators because they have to animate
so many new scenes and they can't reuse
a lot of old animation as much which
an animation tricked just cut down on
production costs and time like when
they're standing around the house a lot
in scenes they can actually reuse
backgrounds that they animated for
previous episodes and just touch them up
a little bit and it saves a bunch of
time there was a clip I put in one of my
videos awhile ago about how the
animators were going on about how crazy
it was to animate Rick and Morty
compared to other animated shows like
South Park with really primitive looking
animation South Park could get an entire
episode out in under a week but that's
just because it's made in such a
primitive way but that's on purpose Rick
and Morty is way more complex as a show
to make the title of the episode is
children of Morty which is a reference
to the early 2000s movie children of men
which takes place in this near future
post-apocalyptic world where the
population just stops being able to have
children the natural way suddenly this
random woman gets pregnant again and
everyone treats her and her child like
this messianic figures and the
government tries to hunt them down and
capture them with a bunch of freedom
fighters trying to protect them I'm
assuming that's a reference to this
dynamic that Beth and Rick and the
family have with these weird gingerbread
looking men pouring out of this volcano
based on the weird colours of the
landscape it just seems like they're on
a family vacation on another planet for
some kind of camping trip because Jerry
is talking about catching fish and he
has a weird trampoline with him for some
reason
not sure why these gingerbread looking
men are pouring out of this volcano but
they kind of sound like meeseeks so it's
just in royal and doing the voices for
them like they had this low level
intelligence but they're not quite as
smart as meeseeks because we know that
the meeseeks are capable of complex
thought and improvisation but rick is
trying to shrug it off like it's no big
deal wanted to move on but for whatever
reason Beth is pissed off and wants to
do something about it seeming like she's
trying to save some of them with the
trampoline the jury brought them as if
that's going to help and I love the
dynamic here because even though they
decided to stay together at the end of
season 3
Beth is back to making fun of Jerry for
not having a job every day is a vacation
for you in a rare moment Jerry actually
agrees with Rick on something that they
should just walk away and leave this
alone way back at Comic Con last summer
they were talking about how this season
there was supposed to be some huge Beth
moment in one of the episodes it sounds
like they were referring to this episode
not something about this time you guys
don't know man we have a dragon see
before that's good it's so good then the
response it's just it's so good finale
of season 4 is really good yeah do we
get konami yeah you have great character
stuff you've seen these they easy just
too much you said too much with that
that's a battle on the special season 5
post-credit scene that they were
referencing also seems like it's going
to be in the finale episode 10 and
speaking of season 5 justin roiland just
did a big rick and morty season 5
interview according to him most of the
season 5 episodes are in the can
relatively speaking and even though they
haven't recorded with the voiceover
actors yet he said that they might
tinker with the animatics a little and
he's not sure exactly what the network's
plan is for airing all the episodes but
he thinks that if they can get them all
done by the end of the year Adult Swim
will just air all ten without a really
huge break like they did for season four
the main reason according to them why
they waited till now to release the rest
of the season it's just because they
didn't finish these last five episodes
in time to air them sooner they also
started hiring new writers for season
six a while ago so they're already
writing their season six episodes so it
just gives you an idea for where they
are in terms of episode production
during that same interview justin rowan
also went on a mini rant about his idea
to only air one episode of rick and
morty every month and then just stretch
each season out for almost an entire
year ten months of a year if there's ten
episodes per season and he claims it in
that scenario the network should be able
to turn each episode premiere into a
much bigger event and it would give the
production team time to finish each
episode on a much more reliable schedule
i don't really agree with him that
airing one episode per month would help
viewership even most major comic books
released two episodes per month and what
are the other issues with that is that
Adult Swim doesn't really have an
advertising budget that's big enough to
do something really huge like that every
single month but he did say that Adult
Swim tries to do something a little bit
different with the way that they drop
each season of Rick and Morty so don't
be surprised if their release schedule
changes just a little bit season to
season but the rest of that clip is just
them going on about how much they love
Batman and the 80s tropes of
wastin vats of acid in how they
challenge themselves to just create an
entire episode around that concept
framing it is a huge Rick I told you so
a moment to Morty say - that is good
good kiss the vet but just a reminder in
terms of the season four episodes
episode 10 will be the finale and as far
as we know we won't get episodes again
till at least the end of the year it's
possible if they don't finish episodes
in time then they'll just wait - next
spring and air all 10 episodes together
so just be prepared in case they say no
more Rick and Morty for the rest of the
year that is a possible scenario my full
video for Rick and Morty season 4
episode 9 will post next Monday just
like I do every week congratulations to
Leonard Thomas Shore the giveaway winner
from my last big Rick and Morty video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for my full Rick and
Morty's Season 4 episode 8 video and
click here for that epic mandalorian
clip of Dave Bologna explaining the Star
Wars prequels it's amazing thank you so
much for watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight!